CD for the best answer and it's kind of
hard I'm so glad I have two but I'm
going to I'm going to give I have to
give it to to oh man there you go does
it come with a CD player by the way if
you do you have a used car cuz a used
car might have a CD player I all right
we got I think we have time for at least
one more question cat head asks if you
could remove one thing from the earth oh
this is great for the sake of all of its
inhabitants what would it be
Tyler I'd say babies on planes babies on
planes yeah yeah how are they to travel
huh how are they to
travel they're not allowed to
travel it's it's just to it's too loud I
bring my dog on a plane and it's more
competing for who gets the most
attention yeah you know I I have a
service dog he gets me uh hot women
that's his service and so if there's a
baby the attention go get you know go
baby get a service baby a service baby
there we go service baby perfect a
little vest on it put a vest yeah you
can probably get that online just Google
service baby no you know what don't
Google service don't do that you'll end
up on Epstein's Island it'll keep the
feminists away it's perfect yes Dana um
uh if you get rid of one thing off this
Earth Ryan
kilme
K I would say mosquitoes oh mosquitoes
are good they're they spread bloodborne
diseases ter they're horrible yeah they
probably hate us I don't think they
really do anything for nature no they
don't like they don't have a purpose no
they don't have a purpose so screw them
right all our God's creatures except you
mosquitoes all right Tulsi I know it's
going to be the same answer as the
previous block
Congress well my first my first
immediate thought was Hillary
Clinton but
I I sat with it for a minute and I'm
going to go with nuclear weapons
ah so what it's hard to decide which
one's more of a
threat Jeff well it's not a popular
answer oh God I'm afraid I had a bunch I
go I can't say that one can't say that
yes and we've arrived at one I probably
also shouldn't say I think we should uh
find a some homes for these people get
rid of these
homeless that was going to be my answer
that was going to be your answer yeah
that that's actually like a PR it's like
can't we get them to figure it out no
one's working on it yeah no one's
working on it and every time I try to
talk about it people go whoa that's
pretty mean and I got I'm just saying I
I I might care more I want them to have
homes yes ex I don't want them to be
homeless yes that's called tough love
yeah they have so much stuff yeah they
do is that weird is that weird some of
it's my
stuff
so you have some motive here yeah well
you know they're scaring people and I
want them to be in a home yeah yeah it's
not saying off the Earth it's like get
him off the street yeah I want to help
help there you go so cat head asks
what's your favorite sound created by
Nature Dana I'm sure you have a nature
sound I mean this one was hard I just
said waves ocean waves ocean waves
that's mine too that's an obvious wow
this is a really power you go yeah
Tyler oh i' probably rain you know
hitting the top of my tent that I live
in thanks a lot Jeff I guess I get going
I want you to have a
home I can see you in a little tiny tent
put a little dirt on my face yeah you
would actually be a good hobo like an
old school hobo hobo yeah with a with a
uh with a tin mug and a little dog with
an eye
patch I said I I look like homeless
Robin Williams I was like oh well thank
you very much bro crap behind that
[Laughter]
dumpster Greg's coming off real
hobophobic yeah H I am hobophobic Jeff
uh what's your favorite sound from
nature uh well I'm a man of the of
nature I like to hike and stuff I live
in Los Angeles and I there was a story
they got kill killed but the bear coming
around the corner I don't if you saw
that on Tik Tok and Instagram but so I
guess my favorite sounds are just of any
kind of animals you know like like a
bear
like that's a good one or a
cougar you know that's a good one or the
birds of where I
live uh it's a great Hillary Clinton
impression yeah yeah going to ask me my
favorite sounds I want to make a meal of
it
yes I don't know I I should have thought
of this too but favorite sound from from
nature h a mud slide oh no one gets hurt
I just like the sound of mud
sliding yeah what is that sound yeah it
goes give goes like
this there it is yeah these are all
homeless people
noises this very anti-homeless it lands
on a
deer I don't know what deer sound like I
have no idea what only guys can do those
sounds yeah true it's true it's true mhm
girl girls don't learn how to do that no
they don't they only can do imitation of
men sounds like yeah
exactly and he was like oh yeah what
about whenever women imitate men it's
always like and then they
say why didn't you turn it on and off
again oh sports sports sports again
sorry honey I forgot oh oh going to work
and making money pay for my shoes yeah
Building Society sorry yeah inventing
penicillin men did that right yes okay
up next why women are putting up a fight
over finding Mr wri hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else